el arquitecto alexandre folk ya no pero
sigue paseando por este bosque de
árboles centenarios que fueron víctimas
de la ira de las balas tras dos meses de
repliegue de rusia en ir pie los daños
medioambientales hacen estragos
alexander jr del agua de pozos como este
antes la media sin temor nombramos todo
esto el problema es que durante la
guerra una gran cantidad de sustancias
dañinas se han esparcido en la atmósfera
xerez ofertamos
junto con el equipamiento quemado y los
humos todo cayó en el suelo y penetró en
el agua
otro problema es la basura durante
semanas alexandre vio como los
proyectiles caían sobre su barrio y la
gente moría los restos de aquella
brutalidad son también una enorme
cantidad de desechos de los edificios
acribillados
antes la gente se paraba la basura y la
reciclamos ahora la cantidad es tal que
sólo se entierra postes y esquinas
román amigo de alexander integró los
equipos que ayudaron a remover los
muertos enterrados en parques y jardines
cuando era imposible darles otra
sepultura
aquí se encontraba una mujer y una niña
pequeña que fueron asesinadas en un
cruce
y
tierra quemada árboles rotos desechos de
los tanques y restos metálicos en
bosques vírgenes la destrucción ha
dejado este paisaje aquí en los pueblos
del norte de kiev en esta zona se dañó
un ecosistema que hasta antes de la
invasión rusa era impoluto al no haber
grandes industrias cerca según el
alcalde de butch a una localidad cerca
durante la invasión incluso los sistemas
de desagüe dejaron de funcionar y esto
ha afectado al medio ambiente
en ucrania diversos activistas luchan
para que se reconozca el daño hecho un
deseo de reparación incierto porque
depende del desenlace de una guerra que
gane quien gane ha dejado sus surcos en
el agua y en la tierra